- (tongue roll) backpack,
backpack, backpack, what up?
♫ We're unstoppable
("Unstoppable" The Score)
It's why all the clients you, it's why--
With your best efforts,
with all the best math
still can't win without the
creative variable in the gray.
So basically what you do as a practitioner
is how I think about about life.
If it was that black
and white it'd be over,
everybody would do it.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Just not the way it is.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You got it brother.
- Thank you.
- [Woman] We have that
11:00 discuss (mumbles)
- Are they here, are they ready?
Yeah, him bring him here.
- [Woman] Okay.
- Thank you.
- [Woman] So what about
the other new hires,
do you want me to hold off on them?
Yeah, you guys will figure
it out, you talk to Tyler.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Z, if you're watching
this, talk to Tyler.
I have no idea what the fuck
is going on when it comes to
logistics because you focus
on the shit that matters.
And logistics, do not matter.
People love logistics.
- You wanna move those new hires?
- To today like maybe on the
back end, or maybe I don't
know, do you want to hold
them off for 10 more minutes?
- Well, Nicholson says he's
gonna be 10 minutes late.
- We're still not ready yet, yeah good.
Talk to Tyler.
My man, it's good to see ya.
- Hey how are you?
- How you been?
- It's good to see you too.
- Yo.
- Had to do it, might as well record it.
- I love it.
- Awe, so nice.
- Happy Birthday.
- I love you, oh my gosh, okay
time to get your autograph.
- You got it.
- It's right there.
- Thank you, enjoy your flowers.
♫ Happy birthday dear Z
♫ Happy birthday to you
- [Gary] Yay.
(office clapping)
- [Gary] Hey Shawn, good to see ya.
- Hey, Gary how are you again?
- [Man] You left these in Vancouver.
- Oh my God yes.
- [Man] During your speaking gig.
- I love it.
I can't wait to rock these.
- Couldn't leave 'em behind
- Me and my team, you should get Nate.
D-Rock, let's get Nate here.
Nate, has never beaten me in tennis.
Like sports is amazing
because you keep score.
Nate.
- [Nate] Is this the tennis situation?
(laughing)
- [Man] He know exactly what's up.
- [Nate] And then I
never did win that game.
I've, also, never beaten Gary at tennis.
Is that what we're talking about?
- We are, Nate.
- Wanna sit down?
- [Gary] Yeah, just for a second,
- [Woman] We need to have
a tennis match. (laughs)
- [Gary] Just for a second, Nate.
As someone who's been
beating me, multiple times,
five-two and then losing,
what do you think is happening there?
In your gut?
- Like why am I not winning?
- More about why am I winning?
(laughing)
It's less about you
Nate, it's more about me.
(laughing)
- Gary digs in, changes strategy.
I get a little loose and
go for too many winners.
- [Gary] That's an
interesting observation.
- And then it gets to
five-three, five-four
then I get tight,
(Gary laughs)
it's just momentum.
- [Gary] It's momentum.
- And, fuck.
- Thanks Nate.
And for all the entrepreneurs
that are watching right now.
Okay cool, maybe you don't have
an 800 million dollar
business but maybe you also,
in parallel, raised two phenomenal kids.
Look what Nate just said.
To answer the question, and this has been
a very awkward interview,
like a little different,
my style, here's the answer.
Ask it again, I want you to ask
the question exactly the same way.
If you can remember how you
asked, or the same energy.
- Sure.
So in the midst of failure,
when you're feeling
so shitty and so horrible, how do you,
actually, gain positivity
and move forward?
- What are some of my strategies
and tactics right?
- Yeah what are some of the
strategies, yeah.
- I dig in.
Nate's answer not mine.
- I booked a set of five tennis lessons.
(laughing)
- And you'll beat me if you dig them.
- I'm tired of (mumbles).
- Now you're doing something about it.
(mumbles)
- Watch this.
70, come on, it's Nate, you like him.
- Seven dollars?
- [Gary] 70.
- 85.
- Nope.
- No deal, I'm sorry.
(laughter)
Can't do it.
- Alright, what are we doing here?
I've historically been fascinated by,
somebody's gotta get bumped
today, it's gotta get replaced.
Somebody else gets bumped.
When is that gonna be great?
Because that's super hard.
- What we're spending all our time on
is context
in your world
- [Gary] And your system,
when you're passing to her.
- And why the calendar works
in these little (mumbles)
- We're living it right this second,
I was supposed to meet
Shelby eight minutes ago.
I'm talking 'bout, if I'm this late--
We're gonna be there at 2:03.
- [Man In Front seat]
You're gonna arrive at 2:03.
- If I'm two hours and change late, right?
I'm two hours late.
These two meeting are now in trouble.
- Right.
- They're gonna be there,
so we're gonna take them,
but at the end of this whole
spiel, when I leave at 6:30,
if something didn't get fit
in here, that's when we gotta
reschedule it, right?
- Right.
- Not something we're
gonna figure out tomorrow.
- [Woman] Yes!
- Do you know what I mean?
- [Woman] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's the big one.
YouTube, super focused.
Long Island city, good
day, had a fire meeting.
I mean, just like a
fire meeting that I hope
they chop up for a podcast, clips.
I'm sure D-rock will find
some time for it in here.
What else is going on?
Jets football.
Obviously the least excited
for a season I've ever been.
It's weird to be Thursday
before the season,
and not be completely
freakin' the fuck out.
Like, didn't see myself
rootin' for the Buffalo Bills.
Anyways, see you later.
What up, what up what up?
- [Man In Glasses] Hey, what's goin' on?
- [Backpack Kid] Hi, Gary.
- [Gary] How are you, man?
- I'm doing good, how are you?
- Such a pleasure, how are you?
My recommendation?
Like if I was, you know, if we came into
this and we're gonna be all partners,
like I quit Vayner Media
and this is my life?
Number one move I'd do is map every single
backpack company in the game from them
if they're number one,
cause you actually like 'em,
and it's hot all the way
down to the one that is
wack and not hot, and look
at it in a room like this
and be like, okay,
reach out to all of them
and be like cool, yo, what's up guys?
And like, what can we do?
And they're gonna say, we'll give
you a ton of shit, we love you!
And you're like, what about money?
No, what about equity?
Of course not, if we're not giving
you money, we're not giving you equity.
Cool, thank you, next.
(tongue roll) You know, JanSport,
you wanna bring that back?
Everything's back.
JanSport, you wanna do something?
Yeah.
What are you gonna give us, free stuff?
Of course.
You gonna pay us?
Sure, how much do you charge?
20,000 a boost.
Cool.
You wanna give us one percent
equity in the company?
No.
Cool, number three. (tongue roll)
Backpack, backpack, backpack, what up?
Hey.
You gonna give us free stuff?
Yup.
You gonna pay us?
Yeah, how much is it?
20,000 a boost.
Cool.
You wanna give us equity?
Yup.
How much?
We'll give you two percent
of the company if you sign
a three year deal, only
wear our shit, da, da, da.
Then you decide.
Cool, thank you.
Next. (tongue roll)
Hello.
Backpack, backpack, backpack,
backpack, backpack, what's up?
- [Backpack Kid] You
can only have one deal.
Sure, notice how I'm calling
everybody? (laughter)
- [Backpack Kid] If I have
to wear this stuff for three
years, I can't wear two
peoples stuff for three years.
- [Man] You're not.
- Ready?
You're exactly right, let's play it out.
If I paid you 100 dollars
to wear one backpack
for the next three years, would you do it?
- [Backpack Kid] No!
- If I paid you 20 million
dollars, would you do it?
- Yes!
That's the game I'm explaining.
What you need to do is get it from no to
100 percent fuckin' yes,
everything in-between,
and then figure out the right spot.
- [Man] I appreciate your time.
- Do your thing.
- I do appreciate it as well.
- Of course.
- [Man] Very generous of you, man.
- Thank you, thank you, guys.
Love you, Boyd.
Yo
(chatter)
- What year did you eating dirt come out?
- 2007
- [Man] Video blog, no?
- Or video blog.
- Podcast (mumbles)
- Podcast was a word, as a
matter of fact, I saw a video,
we were doing some older stuff,
and I called the video show a podcast.
Period.
- Right, it's crazy.
- [Gary] It really is
- Yeah, it's great.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
You'll figure that out.
- I will.
(laughter)
- But, we got Chuck comin'.
- How you doing, Gary?
- What's up, my man?
- My name is QP, CEO of Highbridge.
- Real pleasure.
Real pleasure, Gary.
- Are we going this way?
[Man in Blue Shirt] Yeah.
- Yeah, wanna go this way, man.
- [Shana] Hi, Gary, Shana.
- [Gary] Shana, how you doing?
- [Shana] Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How's things?
- [Shana] Good.
- Yeah, man, good.
- My name is Michelle.
Hey, Michelle, how are you?
- Nice to meet you, how are you?
- All well, good.
Look at this.
- [Man With Long Hair] I know, long hair.
- I'm impressed, man.
You comin' in, you joining,
or are you chillin'?
Yeah, come on!
- [Tall Man] Coming through.
(chatter)
- Life is good?
- Yeah, just trying to keep
my stamina up, playing ball.
- How'd you play?
(laughter)
I've heard every single
logic and rationale
to why not, why yes, why this?
I'm just gonna say one more
time, there's no reason
that I should have twice as
many followers, you know, than
the people I do, you know, I
know the system that works.
Yeah, I got my thing, and I got,
I know I got a little something, but--
You do it right, and you're sitting
right here with 15.5, you know?
I believe in that shit.
So, if we can help in any way
to inspire that, or put you
on to a little information,
I'm thrilled to do that.
Like, I'm not as lucky,
my thing is not as like,
there's not as much sizzle,
and is not as sexy as
what you do, but I'm trying
to make every single person
on Earth know who the hell I am.
So, I get it.
(laughter)
- That's how I feel about
music, like, I don't care
if it's not your type
of music or you don't
like the music, but you gonna
know who I am when you see me.
You gonna know who that
is when you hear me.
- If that's your truth, then
you guys need to get real
serious about distribution,
and I don't mean just the song.
Real serious.
Cause the people that
know how to understand the
distribution, they're the ones who win.
There's a reason that communist countries,
and dictators take control of the media.
Alright, my man.
I'm excited for you, do your thing.
(Sigh) Hip-hop rules the world.
- [Tall Man] Thank you.
- Good?
- Appreciate you also.
Good stuff, it's solid.
- Let's do it, real fast.
Yeah, let's go.
(chatter)
- Yeah, it's that day!
- [Woman] What did, I'm not listening.
- What!
- [Gary] This is an HR issue.
(laughter)
- Gary, let's fix the mic, Sir.
- You got it.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Boogie, hey Boog.
They're gonna take another
photo, then come in.
Good?
Cool, hey.
(chatter)
I'm excited for you, man.
Really nice meeting you, man.
- [Woman With Mac] No hat today?
- [Gary] No hat today.
How are you?
- [Dave] Dave, nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure.
(laughter)
(chatter)
- It's great.
How the fuck, like that
has no prayer in my world
to get anybody to do anything?
So what are you guys thinking?
- Whatever.
- [Gary] I want them to do somethin'.
- Right.
- And there's no prayer right now.
First of all, too much
information, there's no simplicity.
We're not gonna get the
benefits of Facebook
by not making this Facebook native.
I'm not good at like moving
the pepperoni in the,
and you gotta spray the glass,
like, I genuinely mean that,
like I know that you guys understand
that better, this I fuckin' understand.
That's why all my shit
that has no good sound,
no good lighting, and no good anything
fuckin' kills, cause that shit matters.
- [Gary] It's a pleasure, how are things?
- [Man In Light Gray Shirt] It's good.
- [Gary] Good, man.
You are really built like a fuckin' truck.
(laughter)
That's fuckin' crazy.
All right, 20 minutes, sorry 'bout that.
I'll be done shortly.
Where am I going?
My pleasure, how are you?
- How you doing?
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- Good to see you, man.
- [Gary] How are things?
Ready to rock and roll?
- Are we already recording?
- Got to go hardcore and do some
remarkable podcasts back to back.
Just had an incredible
encounter with A Boogie,
an artist that I think is
just outrageously talented.
If you haven't listened to his music,
you're not paying attention.
Netflix came further on
filming, it was just fucking
cameras everywhere all the time now, Seth.
Fucking camera, on camera, on camera.
Fucking, there's ten
fucking cameras in here!
- What up?
- Dude, you crushed that podcast
- Thanks, brother, appreciate it.
- Just did a great podcast!
- I listen to you a lot,
so it was easy to do.
- Just did a great podcast,
guys, it was phenomenal.
I can't wait for you guys to hear it.
We actually talked about a
ton of shit that I don't talk
about often, and that's
getting harder these days
- [Paul] Check it out!
- [Gary] so check it.
- Love how you're holding the camera now,
that's a new thing too.
- Yeah, we're, you know, D-rock
- [Paul] Well, you've
always held your phone.
- D-rock's super sad, he
wants to be YouTube famous.
- [Paul] I saw the new post.
- I'm 'bout to head out, got
a meeting with Guy Oseary,
an incredible music legend,
Beastie Boys, Madonna, just
fucking internet, not internet,
an entrepreneurial mogul.
Gonna do that, Jeff Nicholson,
head of media, 3-4 hour
meeting with him, gonna
chop it up and gonna go
sleep tonight, but before I
get going, yesterday's uh,
two days ago's blog, a couple days ago's
blog came up, let's answer a question.
I'm gonna be getting
in a lot more of this.
Phoebe Mongo, I'm gonna
end it with yours, brother,
wrote, please don't
bleep out the swearing.
We didn't bleep out the swearing
in this episode, we
bleeped out the client.
I fucking swear from the
get forever, and forever,
and forever, and I will
never beep my fuckin' fucks.
- [Camera Man] Problem is,
last episode, we beeped everything.
- [Gary] What?
- [Camera Man] All the swearing.
- [Gary] Why?
- [Camera Man] Know what I mean?
We were just trying it for that episode.
- Cool, let's roll this whole thing.
This is a perfect way to end.
Guys, sometimes they do dumb shit
without me knowing about it.
(laughter)
- See you guys later.
("Where Soul Meets Body" The Muse Maker)
Gary, you good, bro?
Yeah, I'm good.